[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the judge's sentence incapacitates keith
renery
for the rest of his life we dig further
into the case of an alleged sex cult
leader
some of his followers still support him
plus
grand jurors speak out against the
attorney general
who said the cops who shot and killed
brianna taylor could not be charged with
crimes
and a pro baseball player released early
from a mental facility
tries to escape blame after killing
three people with a bat
long crime daily covers court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm erin keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin let's begin
with fallout from the 120-year sentence
handed on against the leader of a
so-called sex calls
terry bring us up to speed on that case
erin a federal jury convicted keith
raniere
of multiple accounts including human
trafficking sex trafficking
racketeering and the sexual exploitation
of a child
the acting u.s attorney said after court
that the 120 year sentence
incapacitates keith renire the
ringleader of the group nexium
this case involving nexium and keith
renery
has really been about many tragedies and
a few triumphs and
what happened in the courtroom today
really really felt like a triumph
it struck me in listening to the victims
that that reneri
really you know twisted people's trust
and their need to find
some meaning and hope in their lives uh
in just the most insidious and devious
ways
when justice catches up with you as it
did today
it it is severe mark elliott and sunil
chakravorti are nexium members joining
us live on law and crime daily
mark glad you're with us have to ask
this question though one of ranieri's
accusers told the court that
she was 15 and that reneri was 45 when
they started having sex
and she said he took pictures she called
it sexual and
psychological abuse is she telling the
truth or is she lying
uh first thank you for having us it's
nice to be here with you guys
uh just to be clear you know any of the
statements
that i make or any of the statements on
behalf of make justice blind
we do not condone abuse in any way
the things that we've been talking about
are specifically to try to expose
uh the prosecutorial misconduct around
this case um
and we believe i mean yes i do believe
that keith renery is
innocent but what what i believe is is
that when people
see the level of misconduct and crimes
that
uh the prosecution and the government
did to convict him
in time then will people then see the
innocence
that i also see um i i can't speak
about whether or not something did or
did not happen
um what i saw yesterday uh and why i
made a public statement
which was so difficult is that there was
a a woman who was allowed to have a
victim statement that was not under oath
or cross-examined um and her statements
uh basically were allowed and played a
role in in condemning a man
to a life sentence uh while you know
our group make justice blind has
presented to the court undeniable
evidence that's been corroborated by
world-renowned uh forensic analysts
um that the hard drive that contained
the alleged contraband
was tampered with and uh the court and
just in general the media has given no
attention to that
that dichotomy i think is a problem in
our country and for the justice system
so you've got issues with procedure and
you've got issues with evidence and you
accuse the prosecutor of committing
crimes that's a pretty harsh statement
sunil i want to switch over to you
though
rainier said he was deeply sorry and
that he caused his own situation
this is all my doing he said in a direct
quote
what did he mean by that you know i was
there i
think that uh you know he feels
responsible for the situation and for
everyone who's been affected because he
was the leader of a community
but as far as uh and feeling sorrow for
the pain and the anger
and the feelings of all those involved
but that can be separate from
someone's innocence i think it was a
good way to take responsibility for the
situation while
maintaining vigorously as he has his
innocence of the charges
so did rainier do anything wrong sunil
in your opinion did he do anything that
he shouldn't have done
i i think that is a broader question
that requires more nuance
i think as far as what our focus is
is looking at you know keith turner was
on trial a jury of his peers found him
guilty he's facing a life sentence what
we're focusing on now and who we want on
trial
is the prosecution and what they did in
this case and exposing that point by
point
so what specifically did the prosecution
do wrong
so i'm glad you asked about a month ago
we as a group of citizens uh
serve the the prosecution with the
document essentially an affidavit
containing eight points of alleged
misconduct from
lying to the court on small and big
matters to lying to the public
to threatening potential witnesses
tampering with evidence and several
other subordinating witness perjury
and we have evidence on
makejusticeblind.com of those things
some of which had come before in motions
to the court and some of which are new
evidence that's coming out
so if people want to take a look at the
details they should they should feel
free to do so
and certainly the documents out there so
mark we've seen pictures of
branding of women that was the evidence
the prosecution presented
what's the explanation for that how do
you take evidence like what you see on
your screen right now
so with respect to the women's group and
and the branding
obviously uh i'm a guy first off so i
wasn't a part of the group and i think
that um you know the the women's group
just actually came out uh they they came
some of the women who are a part of the
creation of dos and members just came
out with a thing called the dossier
project
which i think is an incredible project
where they're
on their own terms and with their own
voice talking about
uh the women's group so um
i that's where i would direct people
where they can learn um
from the people that were actually in it
what this group was about
um there's a funny thing on on youtube
where
if you type in change the soundtrack of
a scene it changes the scene completely
and you know for the past three years
you know people have only heard
one soundtrack uh which i would call a
horror soundtrack
about nexium uh and about this women's
group
and a lot of that is because of what the
prosecution did
um to make it very difficult for there
to be any other narrative
uh mark ignifullo he even
last week submitted a motion from nikki
klein and michelle hatchet
in which the prosecution threatened them
as witnesses
um you know if they uh so that they
wouldn't testify
even myself while the grant while the
jury was deliberating in this trial
i'm an inspirational speaker and i was
putting out a presentation
about my story of how nexium helped me
beat tourette syndrome
um and moira campenza called my
lawyer and my lawyer shared with me that
she said that if i go
through with this public presentation uh
that she would throw me in jail
wow so i
when so just to be really clear these
are these are tough accusations we're
running out of time here gentlemen so
certainly appreciate the conversation
it's a case that we're going to continue
to follow here at law and crime daily
thank you very much for your insight
into the group thank you
thank you a former city council member
and attorney accused of sex
trafficking in ohio is free after
posting bail in other stories we're
watching
michael moran faces 18 felonies
including selling some of his female
clients for sex
a judge set his bail at 300 thousand
dollars in court
miran said he didn't have the cash and
was working to raise the money
ohio's attorney general told law and
crime daily he'd be watching to see who
posted the bail
in case it was a conspirator hoping to
buy moran's silence rather
court records say an indigent defense
fund posted the money
a man is charged in las vegas with
killing a two-month-old baby by throwing
her off a second
floor balcony authorities say the
newborn died from blunt force trauma
32 year old clarence martin jr seen here
is charged with murder and arson
police say he also set fire to the place
and killed a dog in that process
martin took off in a mercedes police
arrested him at the airport
a new hampshire woman is accused of
pretending to be a prosecutor in
filing fake court papers to get an
earlier case against her thrown out of
court
according to an indictment 33 year old
lisa landon
filed a motion to drop her cases using
the name of an assistant county
prosecutor
she's charged with one count of false
impersonation and six counts of
falsifying physical evidence
her underlying case involves stalking
and methamphetamine possession
got to ask about this brian terry
impersonating a county prosecutor by
putting that person's name on your court
papers and saying oh
this case should be thrown out brian i
am looking back at my own case and think
my clients are obviously not working
hard enough to get rid of their own
cases i
i know it's a crime i shouldn't be
laughing
but it's a low-level crime and this is
the most hilarious thing i have ever
seen
a defendant ever do please viewers don't
do this on your own but wow
i don't know how this could have
happened there this is bewildering in so
many levels terry
i mean should they throw the book at her
at this point i mean
what's your take on this actually that
is my take on it i mean it begs the
question what security measures were in
place
and what should we be doing to thwart
these types of fraudulent activities
it's frightening that
she was allowed to impersonate a
prosecutor actually
go in and file papers
and if it hadn't been for this forensic
examiner who was you know scheduled to
perform
an evaluation on landon and he saw that
the charges against her had been dropped
we would not have known about this so
fortunately he was there he contacted
the county he said you know
what happened to the case it looks like
it was dropped and that's how we found
out about it but
my whole point is we need more security
we do that might be one solution here
and still ahead on law and crime daily
the trial of a baseball player accused
of using his bat to commit triple murder
but first
two of the grand jurors who examined the
police shooting of briana taylor
have harsh words for the attorney
general of kentucky as the only officer
indicted heads back to court
we're right back with that report
[Music]
welcome back everybody lawyers for the
louisville career journal are fighting
to get access to discovery materials in
the police shooting of briana taylor
officer brett hankinson has pleaded not
guilty to three counts of wanton
endangerment
for firing shots into taylor's
neighbor's apartment
hankinson's lawyer and the kentucky
attorney general's office have asked the
court to seal the materials
to prevent information from tainting any
potential jury pool
the judge in the case appeared skeptical
of the argument
when you say miss raleigh that the cows
are
let the cows out of the barn i mean in
this case
as we're all aware there's been a lot of
publicity
some of which has been generated by the
attorney general's office itself
so i i have it i find it hard to accept
your arguments
in total because i don't see you coming
to this
with clean hands potential jurors would
would not
be able to set aside this amount
of detail in the public record
two grand jurors who examined the briana
taylor case are speaking out we're going
to jump in now with law and crimes brian
buckmeyer bringing us
up to speed with their harsh criticism
for the process and the attorney general
brian
in an interview with cbs the morning's
gail king
two grand jurors said that the police
covered their tracks
they said they listened to 20 hours of
testimony
and that it was quote betrayal for the
prosecutors and only to only present
one charge against hankinson they said
almost the entire room was shocked when
prosecutors say there were no other
charges
that would stick one said there was an
uproar in the grand jury room over the
way the case played out
they were also very critical of the
attorney general's press conference
announcing the sole charge
the first time i heard the word six
possible murder charges was in that
news conference it wasn't presented to
you in the grand jury
deliberations no no i really felt that
this was
all camera this was up to him we didn't
get a choice in that at all
so i was livid by the time i heard what
he was saying
everything that came out of his mouth i
was saying liar because we didn't agree
to anything
we never met cameron pretty harsh words
there terry from
those jurors a couple of other points
from that interview the attorney for the
grand jurors told cbs that the process
was backwards that
prosecutors wanted the grand jurors to
follow them rather than the other way
around following the law
this was a very unusual case aaron the
fact that these grand jurors are coming
out and speaking
and saying to the public that this isn't
what happened and the fact that they
hired an attorney to help them
reveal what happened is also quite
unusual and brian the grand jurors also
said they found taylor's boyfriend
kenneth walker
credible and totally believable they
said the police were not believable in
those proceedings too many
inconsistencies
that also is very very damaging it's
extremely damaging only for the attorney
general daniel cameron because what
we're seeing
is how a grandeur should not work
this is not the way grand juries work in
any state in any county in any place in
this the united states of america
and what you're seeing is this gentleman
bastardized this process
in a way to ensure that a result that he
wanted
came out rather than actual justice
harsh words from the law and crime daily
commentators as well here for the
attorney general of kentucky and when we
come back here on law and crime daily
the trial of a former professional
baseball player
accused of using a bat to kill three
people two of them relatives
will his mental health defense work
a former pro baseball player was on
trial for allegedly using a baseball bat
to beat three people to death inside a
california home
brandon willie martin faces three counts
of first-degree murder for the deaths of
his father michael martin his uncle
ricky anderson and a repairman barry
swanson who just happened to be there on
a job
prosecutors say in 2015 martin blew
through his 800 thousand dollars in
earnings
had no jobs no friends and no prospects
they accused him of committing the
murders out of anger his defense says he
suffers from mental illness
police officers responded to the
victim's house just days before the
attack for a call
about the defendant being aggressive
towards his family
information i received was that he had
been involved in a physical altercation
with his
with his mother two days prior to a
contact with him
couldn't get a statement from her
because she had left the residence and
speaking with his uh with his brother
that day
he told me that brandon had picked up a
pair of scissors wait
i'm not not going into the facts oh
just why was it that you didn't arrest
him there was
nobody there that was
that wanted prosecution for any any
criminal activity
the based on the information uh given so
far the only other option i saw was
detaining him for a uh placing him on a
5150 hold or a
psyche val like evaluation were they
upset
that uh that mr martin
was placed under 51.50 hold yes
and did you give them the option as to
whether he could be arrested
or placed in a 5150 hold
yes i told him that i didn't feel
comfortable leaving him there so the
only other option would be
criminal prosecution but based on the
behavior
he's been in california the so-called
5150 hold allows for a person to be held
for a mental health evaluation for up to
72 hours
martin's defense said he was released
after only 48 hours
and then went on to commit the murders
and just so it's clear it wasn't up to
them what was going to happen to him it
was up to you
is that right as far as the whole yes in
other words
you're taking in you want input from
these folks but ultimately the decision
is yours is that right
correct okay
was mr martin at all resistant when you
placed him in handcuffs and placed him
in the back seat of the car
no and you were the one that transported
him to the ets facility correct
yes during that drive did you have any
interaction with him
i don't recall any interaction with him
was he at all resistant or combative
in any way on the drive over to the
facility
no and when we come back officers
describe a gruesome crime scene
and a recorded phone call made by one of
the victims
captures the attack that's right after
this
[Music]
let's head back to the trial of brandon
willie martin who's using a mental
health defense to try to beat a charge
which could
send him to death row the victim's
family hired adt
to install a home alarm system when they
learned he was going to be released from
a mental health facility
the technician barry swanson was at the
home working on setting up the alarm
system on september 17
2015. he was on the phone in a recorded
call with his employer
when he was attacked
okay so 138 all
and it's
[Music]
barry can you hear me
do you feel support mr germany may help
you are you still online
authorities responded to the home to
find a gruesome crime scene three bodies
and a baseball bat covered in blood
with the defendant's name etched into it
somebody either had blood on them and
they rubbed up against the wall or
something it could have maybe been a rug
or a piece of clothing or whatever
but something rubbed and the blood was
transferred
or if the blood was already on the wall
it got moved around
so it's not caused this particular
pattern
by blood flying anywhere it's caused by
something rubbing against the wall
could that be if somebody was in the
pool of their
own blood and trying to move and get up
or something
and they had blood on their hands and
wiping it on the wall
could be any sort of movement or contact
between the wall and an object
where there was blood involved terry and
brian back one more time here on lawn
crime daily so terry hard to listen to
that phone call with the employer's
representative basically just saying are
you there do you need help and it's hard
to tell what's going on but it was an
attack
it's a horrible case and it's a tragic
case and it's an ironic case the fact
that the adt
installer himself was there putting in a
system to protect the family against
the individual who ended up killing them
and you know frankly i think that this
is a case of where
the system failed someone who had a
mental illness but
i don't know if there's anything you
could have done to avoid this type of
incident brian is the defense playing
the long game of trying to prevent the
death penalty here and and almost
rolling over on the core murder case or
do you think they've got a shot
by basically blaming the mental health
system for releasing him early
so i think they're actually picking
their battles in california it's a
two-part trial the first
deciding whether or not they're guilty
or innocent and the second part i think
is the major battle they need to win
because they're gonna say that he's
guilty absolutely the facts are pretty
bad on this case
but because of his mental instability or
a mental defect
they're going to try to save his life in
that sentencing phase so terry
what do you think same question to you
do you think they're playing the long
game here or do you think they've got a
shot
by pointing a finger back at the mental
health facility
well i think that the mental health
facility could have done more and i
think it's a good argument but
you know even if they had kept him for
the 72 versus the 48
i don't think that would have made much
of a difference i think what would have
made a difference
had they given brandon the attention
that he needed
the medication that he needed the
counseling that he needed other than
that
letting him out 48 72 hours wouldn't
have made a difference
yeah and it might blow back at the jury
trying to basically blame someone else
for an act that they're basically
admitting that the defendant committed
brian and terry appreciate the
discussion we're out of time here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
for our discussions about justice in
america
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
we break down the case of a serial
killer another day of drama between both
sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law on crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this is lawn
[Music]
crime
[Music]
[Music]
you